vous êtes magnifique vraiment et je
voulais je vous fasse un aveu je vous
trouve encore plus belle maintenant
qu'avant ma mère si vous avez un petit
non mais vraiment vous êtes de plus en
plus jolie
merci alors à la vie quel âge abril à 23
ans non 19 cas la zone avant très bonne
course 19 ans l'a encore jamais un
défaut grec
alors on va le refaire vous allez voir
evènement je suis passé du rêve au
cauchemar
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
by looking for bouger c'est vrai mais
voilà elle est sans avoir aimé elle est
une belle voix sabrina
de la piscine avait un brouillard ou si
j'entendais pas de ta santé entendu que
ce n'est pas la voir beau jeu tout en
chantier aquaboulevard moment pas bien
on ne m'entend pas top